um now as you're progressing through the
exam i don't know how you felt at this
point
like did you look at this and think your
brain melted down a little bit
it's really not as bad as it looks um
it's got
one two three four five tables
right but really kind of it's just it's
one glorified table which means broken
apart normalized
really that's what it is okay in fact if
you think back to the previous question
which is if i scroll back
and you have a look at this table right
it's kind of like this scenario you've
got one table and it describes actually
several things that relate to in this
case loans
okay what you've got when you go to the
next question
is everything in this system revolves
around flights okay
it's just that like i've said they've
tried to reduce redundancy already
and things like airlines and aircraft
which are distinct entities
they're describing in their own tables
rather than lumping it all into a single
flats table
okay so let's start to have a look at
some of the questions
part a three marks three of the easiest
marks on the whole paper
identify an example of an entity
attribute and relationship
within the above schema okay so that one
wasn't too hard
um looking for an example of each one
there we go uh all you had to pick out
was
for an entity just name a table that's
all you have to do because tables
names are after the objects that are in
the system right
so i think the most common example was
an airline people said well an airline
that's the first one okay so that's an
entity you didn't even have to pick
um an attribute from the airline table
but you could
airline id that's an attribute okay
any of these fields is an attribute
a relationship was the third and hardest
mark if you if you didn't get three out
of three here it's because you dropped
it here
um what's your relationship now be
careful here
um because i only had i was i was
doing this like um the hsc right so full
marks wherever i could rather than half
marks that kind of thing
uh if you were close i sort of gave it
to you even if you didn't give me a full
orb to answer
so the best way to say this would be
let's have a look and say airline id
right now pick that out because if
there's airline id
here as well okay so the best way to say
there's a relationship here right based
on this line
is that there's a one too many
relationship
between ah now pause what's the best way
to say this
now most of you would have said
something like a one-to-many
relationship between
um airlines to flights airlines to
flight and that's okay
i paid that that was the money because
it's true right and often
people describe relationships as between
tables
but you may also have noticed that
really like this
relationship is not just between the
entire tables
it's between specific parts of the
tables right and not just that
um you've seen before not in this case i
don't think
no but in some tables you'll have things
like this
you know you'll have one table which
relates to one field in one way and then
relates to another field in the same
table
another way okay like there's a
one-to-one or a one-to-many or a
many-to-many relationship
so the most detailed way to describe the
relationship is actually to say
airline id to airline id
but to distinguish between them you'd
have to say airline id
in airlines and airline id in
flights okay that's a little bit
long-winded but you guys know from sql a
better way to say that
you could say airlines
dot airline id
okay so that's a way of saying in this
table
this field right that field relates to
this field which would be flights dot
airline id okay but like i said
i paid if you said there's a one-to-many
relationship from airlines to flights
because i think
that demonstrator understanding okay so
that was pretty um
pretty universally well done uh part v
is where the what yields started to fall
off a little more okay
there four marks here and they were a
lot trickier to get
let's read it a particular qantas boeing
747 flight
leaves sydney and flies by auckland to
hawaii
describe the records required in each
table to represent this line okay
so pause
what's the question asking what's the
key word firstly what's the keyword
describe okay right there so you can't
just you can't just say what they are
you've got to tell me a little bit about
them
okay but secondly what are we being
asked to describe
it's not that complicated
records about the flight right records
about the flight
now a lot of you like a embarrassingly
high number of you
did not describe records at all um you
described
fields instead okay now fields relate to
records okay
but they're not they're not records the
difference between them is like the
difference between
an entity and its attribute okay so
automatically you surrendered about half
your marks because you just missed the
idea
even if you demonstrated some
understanding of the database
demonstrate the understanding that i was
looking for okay
so how do i go about this uh let's come
back here let me
reset this there we go
let's do this in another color and let
me see if i can walk through it step by
step
and um i was looking for eight eight
records
i think that you need to have um
across all the tables to represent this
one flight
okay so let's go through one by one
a particular qantas boeing 747 flight
okay stop qantas qantas
what does qantas represent in this
situation like
if i if i was going to put the
information that this flight is from
qantas
which table would that information come
from
airlines right should be up here okay so
right away let's come here
right away under airlines i've got oh
sorry
i want the brushes there we go
quartus okay now i don't you know i
actually need to say
that it's it says qantas okay um i'm
just putting this in so that i've know
that i've accounted for all the
information that's in the question
okay so qantas tells me there's airlines
right there's gonna be one
record in this table that tells me okay
that's it's qantas and it's not virgin
and it's not
whoever okay all right next part
uh a boeing 747 all right
what table am i going to be in to tell
me that it's a boeing 747
aircraft right so i'm under here
okay there's my second record okay
because if i want to say it's a boeing
747 there's no record in here
or here or here that's going to tell me
that
there will be a record here but it's
actually going to have to refer to
another record right it'll say boring
747
and it's going to have to refer over
here right so to say boeing 747 here
implies another record okay now
i'm only a few weights of the sentence
so let's keep going now
a particular qantas boeing 747 flight
okay so i've got the airline i've got
the aircraft
and then it says a particular flight
right how many flights are there
there's one because the word is flight
singular now i know i know that seems
obvious but some of you said
two flights some of you said three
flights you're very confused okay
there's one flight one flight um and
it it it says so in the question okay
it even says twice okay so there is
going to be
in the flights table there's going to be
a single record
my third record okay we'll be here
now i keep going what does this flight
do
it leaves sydney and flies via auckland
to hawaii
okay so sydney auckland hawaii now the
first thing we can say
is that there's one two three locations
right
but better than saying locations more
specific than locations which table am i
going to be in
airports right so there are three
airports that have to be referred to
okay
sydney auckland hawaii right so
that's three more so i'm up to four
five six bless you records
okay one here one here one here and
three
in here okay is that all right so far
okay then i have to come back here and
say well
i've got one more piece of information
sort of one
that tells me a little more about this
last step i should have come back
this last table here now sectors what's
a sector
you don't need to know that much about a
sector to know what it
what it must be because the actual
question gives you some information
what do you think a sector is
if you had to guess based on the fields
that you know about it
what would you guess what a sector is
hmm
is it a place you take off
it's it's a place you land right because
there are arrival times
yes there's start times here and there's
arrival times here now
how many places is this flight going to
arrive
two places right because uh here
it has to fly to auckland first and then
it's gonna fly to
hawaii right one landing two landings
so under sectors there's going to be a
seventh and an
eighth record okay
eight records in total okay so how would
you actually word that
in much the same way that i've actually
been saying it you could actually go
ahead and say there'd be a
qantas record in the airlines table you
could say there's a boeing 747
record in the aircraft table you could
say there's a
sydney uh what was it auckland hawaii
you've got to have throughs three
records under airports and so on and so
on
okay and that's it eight records
for marks okay now it tended to be that
if you understood what the question was
about you got all four and if you didn't
really
it was very hard to get like three marks
um to get like say six of the records
and miss two
because if you got six you probably
understood the question well enough to
get all eight
if that makes sense okay so the most
common marks were
um four for getting everything two
because you missed it but you at least
said something useful like say you
talked about
all of the fields which took you a long
time but you misunderstood the question
or like one mark because you tried but
you didn't understand what was going on
okay any questions on that
and by the way this is not that uncommon
of a question and this is the way that i
go about it okay
um i look at see this is what database
schema are not just something which
you know ipt teachers have dreamed up to
make it hard for you to oh man we have
to understand how to draw these stupid
diagrams
they're actually really useful for
representing databases and showing the
relationships and
going through and getting all the data
in a methodical way okay
so even if you don't have a database
schema not that bad an idea
to draw up a rough one so you can make
sure you go through and get all of your
data
make sure you account for it okay